someone from Ariat said get down active  shooter and I saw my peers go down and  we all started running and we were  pretty  we heard it distinctly I just didn't  recognize it the first round was the  second time I did they were getting  closer so I just started running I left  everything I ran I ran I'm in shock she  was ahead of me she turned around she  recognized me and I was worried about my  crew I left my crew they're worried  about them very much and a volunteer at  the festival was pointing to a bus  ladies girls he saw our uniforms run  into this bus go now boom I ran we ran  in theory I was I couldn't run anymore  and I thought he's coming behind me  and I'm gonna get hit because I couldn't  run anymore